you have a paper titled biological
robots perspectives on an emerging
interdisciplinary field and the
beginning you uh you mentioned that the
word xenobots is like controversial do
you guys get in trouble for using
xenobots or what do people not like the
words endobots are you trying to be
provocative with the word xenobots
versus biological robots I don't know
this is there some drama that we should
be aware of that a little bit of drama I
think I think the drama is basically
related to people having very fixed
ideas about what terms mean and I think
in many cases these ideas are completely
out of date with with where science is
now and for sure they're they're out of
date with what's going to be I mean
these these these Concepts uh are not
going to survive the next couple of
decades so if you ask a person and
including um you know a lot of people in
biology who kind of want to keep a sharp
distinction between Biologicals and
robots right see what's a robot well a
robot it comes out of a factory it's
made by humans it is boring it is a
meaning that you can predict everything
it's going to do it's made of metal and
certain other inorganic materials living
organisms are magical they they arise
right and so on so there's these
distinctions I think these these
distinctions I think were were never
good but uh they're going to be
completely useless going forward and so
part of there's a couple of papers that
that's one paper and there's another one
that Joshua night Road where we really
attack the terminology and we say these
binary categories are based on very
um non-essential kind of surface uh
limitations of of technology and
Imagination that were true before but
they've got to go and so and so we call
them xenobot so so Zeno for xenopus
lavis whether it's the frog that these
guys are made of but we think it's an
example of of of of a biobot technology
because
ultimately if we if we under once we
understand how to uh communicate and
manipulate
um the inputs to these cells we will be
able to get them to build whatever we
want them to build and that's robotics
right it's it's the rational
construction of machines that have
useful purposes I I absolutely think
that this is a robotics platform whereas
some biologists don't but it's built in
a way that
uh all the different components of doing
their own computation so in a way that
we've been talking about so you're
trying to do top down control now that's
the electrical system and in the future
all of this will will merge together
because of course at some point we're
going to throw in synthetic biology
circuits right new new um you know new
transcriptional circuits to get them to
do new things of course we'll throw some
of that in but we specifically stayed
away from all of that because in the
first few papers and there's some more
coming down the pike that are I think
going to be pretty pretty Dynamite
um that uh we want to show what the
native cells are made of because what
happens is you know if you engineer the
heck out of them right if we were to put
in new you know new transcription
factors and some new metabolic machinery
and whatever people will say okay you
engineered this and you made it do
whatever and fine
I wanted to show uh and and the whole
team uh wanted to show the plasticity
and the intelligence and the biology
what does it do that's surprising before
you even start manipulating the hardware
in that way yeah don't try to uh Over
Control the thing Let It flourish
the the full beauty of the biological
system why xenopus love is how do you
pronounce it for slavis yeah yeah it's a
very why this frog it's been used since
I think the 50s uh it's just very
convenient because you can you you know
we keep the adults in this in this very
fine frog habitat they lay eggs they lay
tens of thousands of eggs at a time
um the eggs develop right in front of
your eyes it's the most mad magical
thing you can you can see because
normally you know if you were to deal
with mice or rabbits or whatever you
don't see the early stages right because
everything's inside the mother here
everything's in a Petri dish at room
temperature so you just you you have an
egg it's fertilized and you can just
watch it divide and divide and divide
and on all the organs form you can just
see it and at that point
um the community has has developed lots
of different tools for
understanding what's going on and also
but for manipulating right so it's
people use it for um you know for
understanding birth defects and
neurobiology and cancer Immunology also
so you get the whole uh embryogenesis in
the pizza dish
that's so cool to watch Is there videos
of this oh yeah yeah there's been yeah
there's there's amazing videos on on
online I mean mammalian embryos are
super cool too for example monozygotic
twins are what happens when you cut a
mammalian embryo in half you don't get
two half bodies you get two perfectly
normal bodies because it's a
regeneration event right a development
is just it's just the kind of
regeneration really and why this
particular frog is just uh because they
were doing in the 50s and it breeds well
in um you know in in case it's easy to
raise in in the laboratory and uh it's
very prolific and all the tools
basically for decades people have been
developing tools there's others some
people use other frogs but I have to say
this is this is this is important
xenobots are fundamentally not anything
about frogs so
um I I can't say too much about this
because it's not published and
peer-reviewed yet but we've made
xenobots out of other things that have
nothing to do with frogs it's this is
not a frog phenomenon this is it we
started with frog because it's so
convenient but this this plasticity is
not a fraud you know it's not related to
the fact that their frogs what happens
when you kiss it does it turn to a
prince no or princess which way uh
Prince yeah princess yeah uh that's an
experiment I don't believe we've done
and if we have I don't know we'll
collaborate I can I can take on the lead
uh on that effort okay cool uh how does
the cells coordinate let's focus in on
just the embryogenesis so there's one
cell
so it divides doesn't have to be very
careful about what
it so starts doing once they divide yes
and like when there's three of them it's
like the co-founders or whatever like
what like slow down you're responsible
for this when do they become specialized
and how do they coordinate that
specialization so so this is the the
basic science of Developmental biology
there's a lot known about all of that
but um but what I'll tell you I mean
what I think is the kind of the most
important part which is yes it's very
important who does what however because
going back to this issue of of why I
made this claim that
um biology doesn't take the past too
seriously and what I mean by that is it
doesn't assume that everything is the
way it's it's expected to be right and
here's an example of that
um this was this was done this was this
was an old experiment go back to the 40s
but um basically imagine it's a newt the
salamander it's got these little two
tubules that go to the kidneys right
this little tube take a cross section of
that tube you see eight to ten cells
that have cooperated to make this little
tube and cross-section right so one
amazing one amazing thing you can do is
um you can you can mess with the very
early cell division to make the cells
gigantic bigger you can you can make
them different sizes you can force them
to be different sizes so if you make the
cells different sizes the Whole Nude is
still the same size so if you take a
cross section through the through that
tubule instead of eight to ten cells you
might have four or five or you might
have you know three until you make the
cells so enormous that one single cell
wraps around itself
and and gives you that same large-scale
structure by a completely different
molecular mechanism so now instead of
cell to cell communication to make a
tubule instead of that it's one cell
using the cytoskeleton to bend itself
around so think about what that means in
the service of a large scale it talk
about top-down control right and the
service of a large scale anatomical
feature different molecular mechanisms
get called up so now think about this
you're you're you're you're a nude
selling trying to make an embryo if you
had a fixed idea of who was supposed to
do what you'd be screwed because now
your cells are gigantic nothing would
work the there's an incredible tolerance
for changes in the size of the parts in
the amount of DNA in those parts
um all sorts of stuff you can you can
the life is highly interoperable you can
put electrodes in there you'll put weird
nanomaterials it still works it's it's
uh this is that problem solving action
right it's able to do what it needs to
do even when circumstances change that
is you know uh the Hallmark of
intelligence right William James defined
intelligence as the ability to get to
the same goal by different means that's
this you get to the same goal by
completely different means and so so why
am I bringing this up is just to say
that yeah it's important for the cells
to do the right stuff but they have
incredible tolerances for things not
being what you expect and to still get
their job done so if you're you know um
all of these things are not hardwired
there are organisms that might be
hardwired for example the nematode C
elegans in that organism every cell is
numbered meaning that every AC Elegance
has exactly the same number of cells as
every other C elegans they're all in the
same place they all divide there's
literally a map of how it works that in
that in that sort of system it's it's
much more cookie cutter but but most
most organisms are incredibly plastic in
that way is there something particularly
magical to you about the whole
developmental biology process
is there something you could say because
you just said it they're very good at
accomplishing the goal of the job they
need to do the competency thing but you
get freaking organism for one cell
it's like uh
it's very hard
to Intuit that whole process
to even think about reverse engineering
that process right they're very hard to
the point where I often just imagine I I
sometimes ask my students to do this
thought experiment imagine you were you
were shrunk down to the to the scale of
a single cell and you were in the middle
of an embryo and you were looking around
at what's going on and the cells running
around some cells are dying it you know
every time you look it's kind of a
different number of cells for most
organisms and so I think that if you
didn't know what embryonic development
was you would have no clue that what
you're seeing is always going to make
the same thing never mind knowing what
that what that is never mind being able
to say even with full genomic
information being able to say what the
hell are they building we have no way to
do that but but just even to Guess that
wow the the the outcome of all this
activity is it's always going to be it's
always going to build the same thing the
imperative to create the final you as
you are now is there already
so you can you would so if you start
from the same embryo you create a very
similar organism
yeah on except for cases like the
xenobots when you give them a different
environment they come up with a
different way to be adaptive in that
environment but overall I mean so so I
think so I think to you know kind of uh
summarize it I think what evolution is
really good at is creating Hardware that
has a very stable Baseline mode meaning
that left to its own devices it's very
good at doing the same thing but it has
a bunch of problem solving capacity such
that if any if any assumptions don't
hold if your cells are a weird size or
you get the wrong number of cells or
there's a you know somebody stuck an
electrode halfway through the body
whatever it will still get most of what
it needs to do done